oh mein Gott oh mein Gott hey hey ich
kack doch ab ich hasse Horrorspiele
hallo mein Name ist zu kommen meine
lieben Freunde ich darf euch heute nach
Wochen endlich mal wieder begrüßen zu
einer neuen Episode goat Simulator 3 wir
sind hier heute komplett im
weihnachtslook angezogen
das habe ich für heute tatsächlich ein
bisschen was vorbereitet hier vorne ist
ein Barbecue
aber irgendwie ist der Küchen Dings von
denen bisschen mit den wieder gerade
hinsetzen
auf jeden Fall einmal weghauen hier
vorne ist irgendwie jetzt food Explorer
das sieht aber nicht so happy aus ja
schaut euch das mal an sind das
Kartoffeln Pizza
Waffeln also ich weiß nicht was das hält
die zu tun hat aber gut meine Damen und
Herren darum soll es heute nicht
genießen oben schon eingeblendet ich
habe einen Wegpunkt der 920 Meter
entfernt ist Fahrradfahren
ich hasse dieses Spiel
doch ab also wir drücken er sitzen auf
dem Fahrrad Digger ich war doch ganz
normal verarschen Aufstehen er Luft
wir machen das Ganze noch mal komplett
chillig von vorne die laufen zum Fahrrad
hin klicken er fahren los
Leute
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die Bank von den
wollen die denn hier alle vor also gut
ein Fahrrad ich will ein ich will doch
einfach nur verdammen
das Fahrrad jetzt einfach mal an nehmen
es mit und laufen hier vorne auf die
Straße so nicht mehr lecken
[Applaus]
einfach geradeaus
hey ich habe sowas tolles Wort
vorbereitet aber das triggert mich jetzt
wirklich krass dass ich es nicht schaffe
Fahrrad zu fahren einfach eher drücken
und geradeaus fahren
wir scheißen aufs Fahrrad ich würde
sagen wir schnappen uns hier vorne das
Auto fahren einfach
die fahren alle wo will er denn hin
[Musik]
es ist mir auch wirklich alles
scheißegal also wir haben auf jeden Fall
einen Weg wo meine Damen und Herren denn
ihr seht es bereits im Titel
eingeblendet heute geht es um die
horror-ziege ich weiß nicht ob es
wirklich gruselig wird aber das soll so
ein Horror Event hier in goat Simulator
3 sein genau so fahre ich auch immer
Auto wir müssen hier in die Rest Area
quiet Hill und ihr seht auch schon dass
hier vorne alles so leicht vernebelt ist
ich steige jetzt einfach mal aus denn
wir müssen tatsächlich hier vorne in ein
Gebäude rein was glaube ich schon dieses
Gebäude hier ist
oder geht sie schon los
unser Ziel ist es diesen Korridor zu
entfliehen und die Sache ist dass man
wohl immer wieder in den gleichen
Korridor hier reingesetzt wird ihr seht
das schon ich laufe hier vorne rum laufe
in die nächste Tür rein und wir sind
wieder hier das heißt wir müssen
irgendwie das Rätsel lösen um hier
rauszukommen wir haben hier ein Telefon
[Musik]
kann ich nichts mitmachen wir haben hier
auf jeden Fall noch Türen kann ich hier
reingehen geht auch nicht
haben wir hier vorne
es geht auf jeden Fall da hoch
aber ich komme da nicht hoch
gruseliger Bauer geleckt sie nehmen den
jetzt einfach mal mit und schauen ne
hier geht's jetzt nicht mehr lang bis
ich zurücklaufen vielleicht
jetzt auch nicht jetzt ist die Tür offen
können wir jetzt vielleicht durch jetzt
können wir durch okay hat sich
irgendetwas verändert wenn wir jetzt
wieder durchlaufen
um die Ecke Kirschen
das Telefon klingelt
ich habe ein Getränk geleckt
aber ans Telefon
kann ich nicht rangehen ich weiß nicht
ob ich irgendwas machen muss das ist
gerade dafür dass das goat Simulator ist
schon ein bisschen verwirrend
ich weiß jetzt nicht was hier gerade
Phase ist wir können ja einfach mal ihn
hier anlecken und jetzt gucken die nur
oh warum ist wieder der gruselige Bauer
aber da passiert nichts
wir stehen einfach in seinem Bein
[Musik]
ich frag mich hier wirklich gar nichts
mehr wir nehmen diesen Winsen lundwall
einfach mal
wir können niemand mitnehmen oder müssen
wir wieder warten bis die Tür da aufgeht
[Musik]
was muss ich hier machen hier vorne die
Tür ist auch verschlossen da komme ich
nicht durch unsere Aufgabe steht oben
links überlebe wir müssen einfach nur
überleben hier vorne geht gar nichts ab
ich kann wieder hier durch noch kann ich
hier durch hier ist ein Radio Ding wenn
wir das irgendwie anlegen geht auch
nicht oder ich mich direkt daneben
Stelle zack
wir mussten das Radio zerstören um hier
durchzukommen was ist jetzt
[Musik]
irgendwas mit einer Uhr das Radio Ding
ist weg wo haben wir denn eine Uhr sie
vielleicht oben
ja auch keine Uhr wir haben den Bauer
der macht aber nichts hier vorne hängt
ein Seil runter mit nichts
Türen sehen wir irgendwo eine Uhr
das Telefon klingelt schon wieder
ich lauf einfach durch wenn die Tür
offen ist wird sie irgendwas gebracht
haben was haben wir jetzt
wir haben die Uhr aber die Uhr hat jetzt
nichts gesagt
können wir die mitnehmen
ja wir haben die Uhr dabei nee die USA
geblieben
es leuchtet rot
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott hey hey ich
kack doch ab ich hasse Horrorspiele Mann
hey hey der wirft mich irgendwie mit
blauen Bällen ey das ist doch muss ich
denn irgendwie zurückschleudern das ist
doch was ist denn das das ist eine alte
Omi hier die mich hier irgendwie weghaut
so zerstört Kevin Geschützturm weiter
geht's
hey jetzt bitte nicht schon wieder
irgendwie abgeschossen werden was steht
hier im Ecke
die Tür auf
[Musik]
aber ich komme nicht rein ich lauf
einfach mal schnell weiter einfach
schnell weiter mal schauen ob wir wieder
irgendwas passiert vielleicht muss ich
auch schnell sein
Tür steht geschlossen was muss ich
machen ich glaube wenn ich jetzt nichts
mache oder mit nichts interagiere geht's
immer nur so weiter ich muss irgendwas
tun steht das Radio dann wieder hier nee
das Radio ist weg was muss ich tun ich
verstehe es nicht
der neue Tür ist auf
eine neue Tür ist auf sind wir draußen
wir haben es geschafft du hast überlebt
und jetzt sind wir eine spooky
Weihnachts
Ziege mit einem Laken über dem Kopf mir
ist das hier auf jeden Fall alles ein
bisschen zu gruselig wir können doch mal
eben kurz am Strand gehen vielleicht ist
da vorne noch irgendwie was Schönes was
man sich irgendwie angucken kann aber
hier ist halt alles irgendwie auch hi
sind alle irgendwie bisschen
ich brenne
und er jetzt auch oh mein Gott
ja meine Damen und Herren an der Stelle
würde ich allerdings die heutige Episode
Gott Simulator beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat lasst gerne einen Daumen
hoch unter dem Video da abonniert meinen
Kanal und Klick auf die Glocke um
weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen wie
fandet ihr diese Horror Edition guck mal
hier vorne ist dann alles wieder so
spooky hier wieder nicht jeder schon
hier sieht man wieder so Nebel wir sehen
uns auf jeden Fall wieder es war jetzt
eine kleine Horror Episode Gott
Simulator aber das habe ich einige von
euch in die Kommentare geschrieben wenn
ihr weitere Events kennt dich austesten
soll den Gott Simulator wie zum Beispiel
meine komplette Episode im Zoo oder
irgendwas Neues entdecken oder Maus
höchste Gebäude gehen schreibt sie gern
und die Kommentare und tschüss